Okay,
today.
What a,
what a joy.
What a joy.
We start hubs and he's one of the great,
this is one of the great treats.
Okay.
Thomas Hobbs was the author of the first
and I believe undoubtedly the greatest
work of political theory
written in the English language.
Uh,
he was a master of English style and
prose and his work ranks among the very
greatest in this or any other language,
Leviathan is to pros
what Milton's paradise
lost is to epic poetry.
Think about that.
Hobbs was in many ways a
perfect foil for Machiavelli.
He played the part of
Dr. Watson to Machiavelli's
Sherlock Holmes
pubs.
In other words,
carried out
what Machiavelli had
helped to make possible.
Machiavelli,
you remember claimed to have
discovered a new continent,
new modes and orders.
It was Hobbs who helped to make
this new content at habitable.
Machiavelli,
you might say,
cleared the brush.
He was the Lewis and Clark or the
Columbus hubs built the houses and
institutions.
Hobbes provided us with the definitive
language in which even today,
we continue to speak
about the modern state.
However,
uh,
and this is what I want to emphasize,
throughout our reading of Hobbes,
he has always been something
of a paradox to his readers.
And the one hand you will find Hobbs,
uh,
the most articulate,
articulate defender of
political absolutism,
uh,
Hobson,
the Hobson and doctrine of sovereignty
over the hubs and sovereign is to have a
complete monopoly of power
within his given territory.
In fact,
the famous frontest piece of the book,
which is reproduced in your addition,
although it's not altogether very clear,
it's not a very good reproduction.
The famous frontest piece
to the original 1651,
uh,
addition of Leviathan depicts,
the Leviathan,
uh,
depicts the state,
the sovereign holding a sword in one
hand in the sector in the other and the
various institutions of this civilian
and churchly ecclesiastical authority on,
on each side.
The sovereign holds total power over
all the institutions of civilian and
ecclesiastical life holding sway
over a kind of peaceable kingdom
add to this,
uh,
to the doctrine of indivisible
sovereign power hubs,
hubs,
his insistence that the sovereign exercise
complete control over the churches,
over the university curricula.
And over what books and
opinions can be read in taught.
He seems to be the perfect model of
absolutism and have absolute government.
You have to consider also the following.
Hobbes insists on the fundamental
equality of human beings who he says are
endowed with certain natural
and inalienable rights.
He maintains the state is a product of
a covenant or a compact or contract of
kind of a sword between individuals and
that the sovereign owes his authority to
the will or the consent
of those he governs.
And finally that the
sovereign is authorized only
to protect the interests of
the govern by maintaining
civil peace and security.
From this point of view,
it would seem that Hobbes
helps to establish the
language of what we might think
of is the liberal
opposition to absolutism.
And this paradox was noted in
even in Hobbs his own time.
Was he a defender of royalism and the
power of the king or was he a defender or
an opponent of royalism?
I mean in many ways to be sure
Hobbs was a product of his time.
What else could he be?
But Hobbs lived at a time when the
modern system of European states,
even as we understand them today,
was just the beginning to emerge.
Three years before the
publication of Leviathan,
1651,
the signing of the Treaty
of Westphalia famous,
uh,
peace treaty brought an end to more
than a century of religious war that had
been ignited by the
Protestant reformation.
The treaty of vest failure,
um,
officially put an end
to the 30 years' war.
But more than that,
it ratified to decisive features that
would be given powerful expression by
Hobbs.
First,
the treaty declared that the individual
sovereign state would hence forth become
the highest level of authority.
You might say putting an end once.
And for all to the universalist
claims of the holy Roman Empire,
each state was to be sovereign
and to have its own authority.
And secondly,
that the head of each state would have
the right to determine the religion of
the state.
Again,
Dus,
putting an end to the claims of
a single universalist church.
This is what the Treaty of Westphalia,
uh,
put into practice.
And among other things,
what Hobbs attempted to
express in theory in his book.
Okay,
the autonomy and authority of the
sovereign and the sovereign power to
establish,
uh,
what religious doctrine
or what even more broadly,
what opinions are to be taught and held
within a community within a state who
was hot.
So let me,
let me say a word about him.
Hobbes was born in 1588,
uh,
the year that the English naval forces
drove back the invasion of the famous
Spanish Armada.
He grew up in the waning years,
the last years of the Elizabethan era,
and he was a boy when Shakespeare's
most famous plays were first performed
hubs.
Like many of you,
what's a gifted student?
And he went to college.
His father,
who was a local pastor from
the south west of England,
sent him to Oxford,
although he went at the age of 14
and after he graduated,
he entered the service of
an aristocratic family,
the Cavendish family where he
became a private tutor to their son.
His first book was a translation of the
acidities history of the Peloponnesian
war,
which he completed in 1629.
Who Cities The great historian
of the Peloponnesian War,
who we've met a mentioned before.
When we,
when we talked about Plato,
a habits was a gifted classical scholar.
He spent a amount of time
on the European continent,
uh,
with his young two t Mr Kevin dish.
Uh,
and while he spent time in Europe,
he,
he met gala.
He met Galileo and Rene Descartes.
Um,
it was during the 1640s,
the period,
uh,
that initiated the great civil wars,
in England,
uh,
and the execution of the
King Charles the first,
uh,
that hubs left England to live in France.
Uh,
why the fighting went on.
He left England with,
uh,
many of the,
the,
uh,
the royal families,
the aristocratic families who were
threatened by the Republican armies,
uh,
organized by,
by Chrom.
Well,
and that had executed the king.
In fact,
the three justices,
the three judges who were in
charge of the judicial trial of,
uh,
Charles,
the first king,
King Charles,
the one who lost his head.
Uh,
those three judges
later found a home where
in new haven they came to new haven.
The three judges judge Whaley,
golf and Dixwell cause it sound familiar?
Yes.
New Haven was in part started
by founded by members of the,
uh,
you might say the Republican opposition,
to row two to royalty and to the,
uh,
to the,
to the English king in any way.
Hobbs.
However,
it was deeply distressed by the outbreak
of war and you spent a great deal of
time reflecting on the causes
of war and political disorder.
His first treatise,
uh,
a book called Day Civi or day keyway,
depending on how you pronounce it.
I'm the citizen,
uh,
was published in 1642 and it was a kind
of draft version of Leviathan that was
published almost a decade later.
Again,
in 1651 hubs returned to England the
same year of the book's publication and
spent most of the rest of his long life.
A Leviathan was written
well into his sixties.
He was 63 when it,
when it was published.
Uh,
he spent the rest of his long life working
on scientific and political problems.
He wrote a history of
the English civil wars,
uh,
called behemoths,
which remains a classic of the analysis
of the causes of social conflict.
And as if this were not enough
near the very end of his life,
uh,
he returned to his classical studies
translating all of Homer's Iliad and
Odyssey.
Uh,
he died in 1679 at the age of
91 from the various portraits,
uh,
and descriptions of Hobbs.
Uh,
we can tell he was a man of considerable
charm and I wish the book that we had
had his picture,
a reproduction of this portrait on it,
but I just want to read,
uh,
one brief passage from his biographer.
A man named John [inaudible] who knew him,
uh,
who,
who knew him.
It was written during hubs is lifetime.
Aubrey wrote about Hobbs.
He had a good eye and that of Hazel Color,
which was full of life and
spirit even to the last,
when he was earnest in dis,
in discourse.
These shown as it were,
a bright as if a bright
live coal within it.
He had two kinds of looks when he laughed,
was witty.
And in a Mary humor,
one could scare see his eyes.
And by and by when he
was serious and positive,
he opened his eyes around.
He was six foot high and something better.
So it was very,
very tall.
In the 17th century,
he was six foot high and very better.
He was.
He was,
he had read much if one
considers his long life,
but his contemplation was
much more than his reading.
He was want to say that he did it,
that if he had read as much as other men,
he should have known
no more than other men.
Uh,
so his point was he had read a lot,
but what was most important was his,
his thinking,
if he had red is not as much.
He would know his little.
Let's do a little sense of hubs,
his spirit,
his humor,
the wry wit that becomes a parent on,
on almost every,
every page of this book.
But you have to be a careful reader.
Hubs was deeply controversial,
as you might suspect during his lifetime.
Leviathan was excoriated by almost every
reader of the text to the church men.
Uh,
he was a godless atheist,
uh,
to the Republicans.
He was tainted with monarchy or
monarch ism and to the monarchists,
he was a dangerous skeptic.
Uh,
and free thinker hubs.
Again,
along with Machiavelli was one of the
great architects of the modern state.
And to some degree he even seems to speak.
He see,
he seems even more characteristically
modern than Machiavelli.
I mean,
considers just some of the following.
Machiavelli speaks of the prince while
hubs speaks of the sovereign that is a
kind of impersonal or
in Hobbs is language,
artificial power,
uh,
created out of a contract.
Hobbes is method,
seems scientific.
It seems formal and analytical in
contrast to Machiavelli's combination of
historical commentary in reflection
drawn from personal experience.
Well,
Hobbs,
I,
excuse me.
While Machiavelli often
spoke of the sublime cruelty,
uh,
of men like Skipio and Hannibal hubs
speaks the more pedestrian language,
the language of power politics,
where the goal is not glory and honor,
but self preservation.
And Machiavelli's emphasis
upon law upon arms,
uh,
is considerably attenuated by Hobbs,
is emphasis on laws.
Hubs,
in other words,
tried to render acceptable,
tried to render palatable.
What Machiavelli had done by providing
a more precise and more legal and
institutional framework
for the modern state.
So let's think a little bit about what
it was that Hobbes was attempting to
accomplish.
Okay.
Hubs like Machiavelli was an innovator
and he was self consciously aware of his
innovations,
can like Machiavelli who said in the 15th
chapter of the prints that he would be
the first to examine the effectual truth
of things as opposed to the imaginings
of them.
Hubs wrote that civil science,
that's what he called political science.
Civil Science was no older
than my book day Keyway,
modern political science,
he said began with his,
this book of 1642.
What,
what did he think of as his novelty?
what was new?
What was revolutionary about or innovative
about Hobbs is political science.
Hobbes clearly saw
himself in many respects,
is founding,
uh,
political science modeled along that
of the early founders of the scientific
revolution.
Galileo,
I've already indicated that
Hobbes had met William Harvey,
Rene Descartes,
a handful of others who were part of
what we think of is the modern scientific
revolutionaries.
Unlike these other revolutionaries
who had overthrown a,
you might say,
the Aristotelian Paradigm in natural
science hubs set out to undermine the
authority of Aristotle in civil science,
in political and moral science.
Hobbes set himself up as
the Great Anti Aristotle,
the great,
uh,
opposition to Aristotle considered just
the following passage from Leviathan
with one of my favorite
titles from the book,
a chapter called of darkness from vein
philosophy and fabulous traditions.
In that chapter,
Chapter 46 hobs writes,
there is nothing so absurd that
the old philosophers have not,
some of them maintained.
And I believe that scares anything
could be more absurdly said in natural
philosophy then that which is now
called Aristotle's metaphysics normal
repugnant to government then much
that he has said in his politics,
nor more ignorantly then a
great part of his ethics.
So there you say Hobbs
laying down a challenge.
What was it that he
claimed to find so absurd,
repugnant and ignorant,
uh,
in Aristotle.
Why did he,
what did he,
what was he trying to and thrown?
D dethrone and Aristotle.
Okay.
Hubs is typically concerned,
uh,
with the foundations of this new science.
Getting the building blocks
right from the beginning,
the opening chapters of Leviathan,
which I've only assigned a few,
but the opening chapters present a kind
of political physics where human beings
are reduced to body and the body is
further reduced to so much matter and
emotion.
Human beings can be re reduced
to their movable parts,
much like a machine.
What does life,
he asks rhetorically
and in the introduction,
what is life but emotion of the limbs?
What does the heart but a spring or reason
but a means of calculating pleasures
and pains
he sets out to give a deliberately
and thoroughly materialistic and non
teleological physics of human nature.
In fact,
a French disciple of
Hobbs in the next century,
a man named La Tree,
uh,
wrote a treatise very much following in
the lines of Hobbs called Lum machine or
literally man a machine.
This is the way Hobbs Hobbs is.
New Science of politics appears to begin
and that new beginning is intended to
offer in many ways it comprehensive
alternative to Aristotle's
physics or Aristotle's politics.
Aristotle argues that all
action is goal directed,
is goal oriented.
All actions aim at
preservation or change it,
making something better or
preventing it from becoming worse.
Hubs believed,
on the other hand,
did the overriding human fact,
uh,
of the overriding motivation of
human behavior is largely negative,
not the desire to do good,
but the desire to avoid some evil.
Aristotle for Hobbes had simply seeing
the world through the wrong end of the
telescope.
For Aristotle,
human beings have a goal or a t loss,
which is to live a life in community
with others for the sake of human
flourishing.
But for hubs,
we enter into society,
not in order to fulfill or
perfect our rational nature,
but rather to avoid the greatest evil,
namely death or fear of
death at the hands of others.
Politics for him is less a matter of
prudential decisions of better and worse
than it is,
you might say,
an existential decision of choosing
life or death for Hobbs in many ways.
As for Machiavelli,
uh,
it is the extreme situation of
life and death of chaos and war.
They'd come to serve as the norm for
politics in political decision making,
fundamental alternative
or challenge to Aristotle.
And furthermore,
Hobbs not only criticized you
might see the foundations,
the motivational and
psychological foundations,
uh,
of Aristotle's theory of
politics and human nature.
He blamed the influence of Aristotle,
uh,
for much of this civil
conflict of his age.
Aristotle who was increasingly
being embraced by Civic
Republicans in England of
his time,
uh,
had been brought up according to
Hobbs on Aristotle's teaching.
That man is by nature a political animal.
This was again,
the thesis of the classical
Republican's according to which,
uh,
we are only fully human or we only
become fully human when we are engaged in
political life,
in ruling ourselves by
laws of our own making,
which was a doctrine that Hobbes
attributes to many of the,
uh,
teaching,
much of the teaching at the university,
the universities of his age.
And it is precisely this
desire to be self governing.
You might say to rule directly,
you have a direct part in political rule
that saw Hobbs is one of the great root
causes of civil war.
And his answer to Aristotle and the
classical Republican's of his age was his
famous doctrine of what we might call
indirect government or what perhaps would
be more familiar to us by the
term representative government.
The sovereign
is not four hubs.
The people or some faction of the people
ruling directly in their collective
capacity.
Uh,
the sovereign is four hubs.
The artificially reconstructed will
of the people in the person of their
representative,
the sovereign representative act,
you might say like a filter for the
wills and passions of the people.
The sovereign is not the direct
expression of my will or your will,
but rather an abstraction from my
natural desire to rule myself in.
In other words,
instead of seeking to participate
directly in political rule,
Hobbes wants us to abstain from
politics by agreeing to be ruled by this
artificial man is,
he calls it this artificial person or
representative that he gives the name,
the sovereign
four by art.
He says in the introduction for by art
is created that great leviathan called
the Commonwealth or the state,
which is but an artificial man though
of greater stature and strength than the
natural for whose protection
and defense it was intended to.
Sovereign,
he says,
are Leviathan,
this great artificial man.
It isn't that the sovereign is something
more like what we would call today an
office rather than a person is when we
speak of the executive as an office.
Uh,
and it is the,
it is simply the person
who inhabits the office.
Uh,
although
that might be somewhat questionable in
some of our recent executive decisions.
But for Hobbes,
Hobbes creates this office of,
of of a political of
call call the sovereign.
Now there's language in that
sentence that I just read from,
from the introduction for by art again
is created that great leviathan called a
Commonwealth or state when
hubs uses the term art,
there are four.
By art is created.
That term is deeply
revealing of his purpose.
Again,
for Aristotle,
by contrast,
art presupposes nature or in other words,
nature precedes art.
Nature supplies the standards,
the materials,
the models.
For all the later arts,
the city being by nature,
man by nature,
nature provides a
standard nature proceeds,
art and human artifice or human making.
But for Hobbs.
Think of this,
think of this by contrast are,
does not so much inner imitate nature.
Rather art can create a new kind of nature
and artificial nature and artificial
person as it were.
Do Art again is created
the Great Leviathan.
Do art properly,
understood and buy art?
Of course.
I mean something like human making,
human ingenuity,
human art,
Ful,
ness,
uh,
through art we can begin
not just to imitate,
but we can transform nature.
Make it into something of our own.
Choosing art here is not to be understood
also is the antithesis of science is
when we speak of the arts
and the sciences rather.
Science a is the highest form of art.
Science is the highest kind
of human making a science
or what Hobbs simply calls
by the term name reason is simply the
fullest expression of human artfulness
reason he stays in chapter five.
Reason is not as sense
and memory born with us.
Reason is not born with us
nor gotten by experience,
only he says,
but is it tainted by industry?
First in APP imposing of names.
And secondly,
by getting a good and orderly method.
I think of those terms,
um,
reason and again,
he uses this synonymously with other
terms like science or art is not simply
born with us.
It is not simply a genetic endowment nor
is it simply the product of experience
which Hobbs caused by the name prudence,
but rather reason.
He says,
is it chained by industry by uh,
by work and it's develop.
First he says bite you the imposing
imposing of names on things.
The correct names aren't things.
And second,
by getting a good and orderly method of
study reason consists in the imposition
of a method for the conquest of nature
by science hubs tells us he means the
knowledge of consequences.
And especially he goes on to say when we
see how anything comes about upon what
causes and by what manner.
When like causes come into our power,
we can see how to make
it produce like effects.
We can see how to make it produce like,
like effects a reason.
Science art is that is
the capacity to transform,
transform nature,
uh,
by making it,
imposing on it a method that will
produce like effects after similar
consequences.
There is,
in other words,
that kind of radically transformative
view of reason and knowledge and science,
political science,
civil science running
throughout Hobbs is work.
Reason is not about simple observation,
but rather it is about making production.
Or as he says,
making light consequences
produce the desired effects.
We can have a science of politics.
Hobbes believes we can ever civil science
because politics is a matter of human
making,
of human doing,
of human goings on.
We can know the political world.
We can create a science of
politics because we make it.
It is something constructed by us hubs.
This goal here is,
is it worth to liberate knowledge to
liberate science from subservience or
dependence upon nature or by chance,
by on Fortuna,
by turning science into a tool for
remaking nature to fit our needs,
to impose our,
uh,
needs or satisfy our needs through,
through our science,
art,
and especially the political art
is a matter of reordering nature,
even human nature.
First according to Hobbs,
by resolving it into its most elementary
units and then by reconstructing it so
that it will produce the desired results,
much like a physicist,
uh,
in a laboratory mice,
this is Hobbes is answer to Machiavelli's
famous call and chapter 25 to master
for tuna to master chance or luck fortune.
But you might say,
hubs goes further than Machiavelli.
Machiavelli said in that famous
chapter 25 that the prints,
if he's lucky,
will my master for tuna
about half the time,
only about 50% of the time,
the rest of human action,
the rest of state craft
will be really left to,
to chance luck,
contingency circumstances.
Uh,
Hobbes believes that armed
with the proper method,
with the proper art or scientific doctrine
that we might eventually become the
masters and possessors of nature.
And I use that term masters
in possessors of nature,
a term not of Hobbs is making but of
day coat from the sixth part of the
discourse on method because I think it
perfectly expresses Hobbs as aspirations
to not only to create
a science of politics,
but to create a kind of immortal
Commonwealth which is based on science and
therefore based on the proper
civil science and therefore
will be impervious to
fluctuation,
a decay,
uh,
and war and conflict which all
other previous societies have,
have experienced.
You can begin to see in other words,
in Hobbs is brief introduction to his
book as well as the opening chapters.
Uh,
you can really see the
immensely transformative and
really revolutionary spirit,
uh,
underlying,
this,
uh,
this amazing,
amazing book.
Oh,
so where do we go from here?
We turned from methodology and science
to politics.
Um,
what is Hobbes is great question.
Always important when reading,
starting out with a new book,
asking yourself what question
is the author trying to answer?
What is the question?
And it's not always easy to ask answer
because sometimes they don't always make
their deepest or most
fundamental questions altogether.
Clear.
In the case of Leviathan,
I would suggest to you,
uh,
hubs is central.
Central question is what
makes authority possible.
What is the source of authority?
And you might say,
what renders it legitimate?
Maybe the question is what makes
legitimate authority possible?
Still,
this is still a huge question for us when
we think about a Cree nation building
and building new states,
uh,
how to create a legitimate authority.
Obviously there's a tremendous issue
with this in Iraq today is we try,
it's people there and
here struggle with what,
what would,
what would constitute
a legitimate authority?
Perhaps we should airlift,
uh,
copies of Leviathan to
them because that's hubs.
That's the issue that Hobbes is
fundamentally concerned with.
How his,
his question goes further.
How can individuals
who are biologically autonomous,
who judge in see matters very differently
from one another who can never be sure
whether they trust one another?
How can such individuals
except a common authority,
and again that is not just
what constitutes authority,
but what makes authority legitimate.
That remains not only the
fundamental question for Hobbs,
but for the entire,
at least for the entire social contract
tradition that he helped or he he,
he helped to establish.
You might say,
of course,
the question what renders authority
legitimate is only possible.
It was only raised when
authority is in question.
That is to say when the rules Governing
Authority has broken down in times of
crisis and that was certainly
true in Hobbs is time,
a time of civil war and crisis.
What?
What renders authority
legitimate are respectable.
And to answer that question,
hubs tells a story,
okay.
He tells a story about something
he calls the state of nature
a term he did not invent,
but with which he will his name will
always and forever be associated.
The idea of the state of nature.
The state of nature is not a gift of
grace or a state of grace from which we
have fallen is in the
biblical account of Eden.
Uh,
nor is this is the state of nature,
a political condition as maintained
in some sense by Aristotle.
When he says the Polis is by nature,
the state of nature for hubs,
uh,
is it condition of conflict and war?
Okay.
In by a state of nature,
he means or by a state of war,
he means a condition where there is no
recognized authority in his language to
keep us in awe,
no authority to awe.
Uh,
us,
uh,
such a condition.
State of war may mean a
condition of open warfare,
but,
but not necessarily it can signify battle,
but hubs says it can also signify the
will to contend simply the desire or the
will to engage in conflict
renders something.
Uh,
like a state of nature.
A state of war can include,
in other words,
what we might call a Cold War,
uh,
to hostile,
looking at each other across
a barrier of some type,
not clear or not certain
what the other will do.
So the state of nature is not necessarily
a condition of actual fighting,
but what he calls a known
disposition to fight.
If you are known or believed
to be willing to fight,
you're in a state of war.
It is a condition for
hubs of maximum security.
Where in his famous
formula life is solitary,
poor,
nasty,
brutish and short.
Okay.
Perhaps he should have said,
fortunately short.
Uh,
this is the natural condition,
the state of nature,
the state of war that
Hobbes attributes to,
uh,
again the fundamental
fact of human nature.
Now his claim that the state of nature
is the condition that we are naturally
did.
The state of war rather is a
condition that we are naturally in,
is to say among other things that nature
does not unite us in peace and harmony,
in friendship or in solidarity.
If nature is a norm,
uh,
it does not,
again mandate or incline us to peace,
friendship and solidarity with others.
Only human art or science or art.
Human contrivance can bring about peace,
conflict in war.
Our primary piece is derivative.
In other words for Hobbs Authority and
Relations of authority do not arise
naturally among us but are rather again,
like civil science itself,
the product of contrivance or art.
So the question for us remains is it
was deeply challenged readers and Hobbes
his own time.
What makes hubs is story is I'm calling
it his story about the state of nature
being a condition of what,
what makes it plausible,
what makes it believable?
Uh,
as an account of,
again,
the condition we are naturally in,
why should we believe Hobbs is story?
Uh,
and uh,
not,
not some other story
from,
no,
I just want to say a word about that.
Before closing
from one point of view,
bleeding Hobbs,
his account of the state of nature seems
to derive from his physics of motion
and rest in the opening chapters
of the via and he begins to work.
You remember,
uh,
within an account of human nature,
kind of human psychology as product
is a product of sense and experience.
We are bodies in motion and who cannot
help but obey the law or the physics of
attraction and repulsion.
We are bodies in constant motion.
He seems,
in other words,
to have a kind of materialistic psychology
in which human behavior exhibits the
same as it were,
mechanical tendencies as billiard balls
that can be understood as obeying again,
geometric or causal processes
of cause and effect,
right.
The state of nature is not seen by him,
uh,
as an actual historical
condition in some ways,
although he,
he occasionally,
uh,
we'll refer to what we might think
of as anthropological evidence to,
um,
to support his views
in the state of nature.
But the state of nature for him,
uh,
is rather a kind of thought experiment,
after the manner of experimental science.
It is a kind of thought experiments
consists of taking human beings who are
members of families of
estates of Kingdoms and so on,
dissolving these social relations
into their fundamental units,
namely the abstract individuals.
And then imagining again in the
manner of a chemist or a physicist,
how these basic units would
hypothetically interact with one another.
Again,
almost like the properties of
chemical substances in some ways.
How would we behave in this?
Again,
this,
this kind of thought experiment
that would be one way of
reading or that Hobbes seems to,
wants us to think about
the state of nature as a,
as again,
an expert,
as,
as a kin to a scientific experiment.
Uh,
hubs is the,
again,
the great founder of what we might call
the x among others is the experimental
method in social and political science.
And there's a reason perhaps
a reason for this too,
and I'll end just on this note.
When Hobbs was a young man,
uh,
he worked as a private
secretary for a short time,
a private secretary to uh,
another very famous Englishman
by the name of Francis Bacon,
the great founder of what we think
of as the experimental method.
Uh,
the method of trial and error
of experience and experiment.
Uh,
and it arguably Hobbes was
influenced in many ways by,
by Bacon's own philosophy of experience.
And experiment and Hobbes took
Bacon's method in some ways,
applying it to politics,
tried to imagine,
again,
the natural condition of human
beings and what we are by nature,
by UB strapped,
by a process of abstraction
and abstracting all of the
relations and properties
that we have acquired over history,
through customed to experience
stripping those away,
like the layers of an onion and putting
us almost as it were in an experimental
test tube or an under a microscope.
Seeing how we would,
uh,
under those conditions react
and behave with one another.
I'll leave it at that,
although I want to tell,
I will start next week by showing how
that view of hubs is only at best,
partially correct.
Uh,
so anyway,
have a wonderful weekend
with your parents here and,
uh,
I'll see you next week.